[Musique]
ce mercredi 18 juillet sur le site pic
adam à bois de nèfles saint clotilde les
services du conseil départemental
la direction régionale de l'eau nf ont
mis en place l'opération d'enlèvement
des poubelles
c'est ce que nous explique alain
fontaine responsable de la communication
à l'eau nf
donc on va enlever les poubelles et
cette sensibilisation ce déséquilibre de
feu ne se fera pas tout seul on va
simultanément porté une campagne de
sensibilisation vers les scolaires à
grand renfort de supports pédagogiques
des plaquettes et des affiches pour les
aider un nom a collaboré à cette à cette
opération et sur les sites où on a des
équipes et en poubelle on mettra des
pictogrammes qui expliqueront aux gens
le pouvoir de notre action est bien sûr
une action qui se veut pacifique
on a besoin de tout le monde à l'heure
où les vacances battent leur plein cette
période d'affluence est l'occasion de
sensibiliser à la protection de notre
environnement par le biais d'un message
éco citoyen fort ramener nos déchets à
la maison gardons notre port est propre
[Musique]